foreign
over 600 pounds everything is just a
mess right now you snap your fingers for
me right now what would be different I
would have enough money to support
myself be able to help my friends out
when they needed it
I need you to hear me say man that is
not the answer I was expecting
[Music]
what is going on what is going on what
is going on this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
show about you your mental and emotional
health
families your marriages your kids
whatever you got going on in your life
and walking alongside people for more
than two decades now sitting with them
when the wheels have fallen off and they
have to ask that scary question what am
I going to do now and my promise is I'll
show up with you and I'll pull up a seat
in the muck and the mire and we will
figure out what happens next if you want
to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask also if you are frustrated by the
state of the world and you think
everybody's just acting the fool and
being goofy and you wish that they would
just get
just go subscribe or click the thumbs up
button I don't know how all that stuff
works just tell the internets that you
are a subscriber to the show however
however you do that
it kicks the show up in the algorithms
and it helps us for no cost it doesn't
cost us anything it helps us get this
show out and the message out to more and
more folks so so so grateful for you
um let's go out to Sean in Moses Lake
what's up Sean
how you doing John partying man what are
you up to
oh not much just about ready to get the
day started here I figured I'd talk to
you first
my wife figures the exact opposite on
most mornings so good for you man good
for you what's up
um all right well I got myself in a
little bit of a situation here okay
um I'll give you a quick back story real
quick um so I had a alcohol withdrawal
related seizure September 21.
and I have no legal trouble or anything
like that
um so then my grandpa so I quit after
that and then my Grandpa died February
22. so I started slowly coming back and
doing what I'm not supposed to be doing
and then so uh November of
uh 22 to December of 22 I went to
treatment in California came back was
doing good through the holidays IOP AAA
Celebrate Recovery counseling with my
wife Lexi
um but then I started to relapse like
every three to four weeks just like
single day single night relapses and
not really understanding why until
afterwards and that pushed Lexi and Owen
my son to her mom's house we still are
cordial and see each other quite often
but they're in town and I'm out we have
20 acres out here in a little farm
and so my two questions are is
could you help me understand what like I
I after all this treatment that I've
been to I still am not understanding
until I'm not noticing what I just did
until at like the next day like why the
hell did I do that
you know and then the second question is
I'm really a relationship oriented guy
and I've been with Lexi for over 17
years now so how should I deal with that
loss of communication with her without
going stir crazy out here by myself yeah
that's a great question man
um so you're my dog my dog Rossi and she
doesn't speak very good English
yeah but she probably loves you more
than more than most
um
and you've been through hell the last
year or two huh
yeah
and you've been held through hell way
before that too huh
yeah but it was never like I said I've
had no legal problems I was I don't care
about that I don't care about that I
don't care about that okay there's a lot
of people who are
in the nerd world we call it long tail
suicide
who are okay quietly drinking themselves
to death and no one will ever know
because they're gonna say I got
pancreatic cancer I had liver issues or
I had a stroke
and no one's going to realize that for
the last 30 years they quietly
um drown themselves in the company of
people who love them
yeah so I don't care about legal trouble
man I care about Sean who's sitting in
front of me
who's looking at his life and and has a
different picture of what this could
look like man and you just feel Tethered
to the old one right
yeah
so
I
my instinct is to call bullcrap on
um in a loving way right if we're
sitting here to be smiling but I would
say I call bullcrap on
I just black out and I wake up the next
day and I was drunk the night before
there's always a moment yeah and
like and it's it's their and I know that
like
these situations they just kind of pop
up out of the blue I know it's not an
excuse but you know what sets you off
what is it
um I want to say
like
my like friendship if like a friend is
coming over or something like that you
know relationships
so if I wanted if a friend is coming
over if your wife wants to to get close
with you that's when you drink
well I mean I'll have friends like I
just went to Dallas for five days and
didn't drink the whole time I was down
there sure because that's a new
environment yeah yeah and I
and like I say it's just it's for me
it's answer my question though brother
when you're sitting here what happened
but friendship are you drinking because
you're lonely are you drinking because
you got friends coming over I think I
think I think because I'm because I'm
bored
there you go yeah
and like uh like my old routines of like
out on the tractor having a beer in my
hand you know that that type of thing
that's right
so all the things you just rattled off
Celebrate Recovery AAA counseling with
my wife trying to do this trying to do
that
you are trying to do so much all at the
exact same time
yeah I would love to see you
back out a little bit
and have One Singular goal for six
months and that is to stay Stone sober
we're not going to also dig into my
childhood past we're not going to also
dig into how can I communicate better
not going to dig into the shame
associated with you love this woman for
17 years but you've dragged her through
the mud too
We're not gonna do any of that
we're going to create a structure around
staying sober
because what you're trying to do man
it's like you have a stomach virus and
you keep throwing up and you're also
trying to clean up the house at the same
time and meet with a roofing contractor
and test out new counter wipes the first
thing you got to do man quit barfing
right
yeah and that's that's the challenge
and yes
um
it doesn't surprise me that it's easy
for you when you're in a new environment
to stay clean because your body doesn't
fall into those old rhythms the the
challenge you gotta you gotta be honest
with yourself about is a
and I live on some makers too and so I
get what I'm asking you is that the
place for you
well see that's the that's one thing too
we were uh
um my wife Lexi she's a consultant
pharmacist and she has an opportunity to
move to St George in Utah and we're
seriously thinking about a new
environment
I don't know that that's necessarily A
Bad Thing
yeah
and maybe it's something where you hang
on to your property and y'all go down
there and rent for a season
yeah we're we've been talking through
that the last couple weeks okay
your wife has to understand and believe
that healing is coming but you can't do
it all at the same time and she's going
to want to get her 17 years back
yeah and she's going to want to get
especially the last two or three years
back and she wants to get back how
scared she was when you had that seizure
and she wants to get back all that right
now and that's just not how healing
works
yeah
and like
and it makes me feel terrible I know it
does but that starts the cycle over
again
yeah
you feel terrible and then your body's
way of dealing with terrible is to
unplug when you unplug you get bored man
and I gotta feel something
I don't want to feel shame and I can
feel this and this is awesome
is that fair okay yeah that's fair
and you know it's uh what keep what
keeps you from calling your sponsor
um I don't have a sponsor yet I call my
buddies to keep me me Focus today
really that ends today
you have to get a sponsor to hold you
accountable
bro your way has not worked it's not
worked has it I know nope
you gotta say for the next 60 days I'm
going to AAA every single day and I will
get a sponsor and I'm gonna go through
the whole rigmaru as much as you roll
your eyes and oh my gosh it's so stupid
and they get on your face or whatever
they want to sing Kumbaya whatever they
want to do
that's where because my Way's not
working
yeah
because I I mean I was doing AAA every
day and
but then I just kind of got out of that
Rhythm you did you did it part way
yeah you went to meetings but you didn't
connect with people right
I kind of dad was there probably going
for three or four months you know but
you never got you never got a spot you
never got somebody's number to call when
you felt the need to use no yeah no you
just you you were playing it hey you
went halfway
okay
and here's the thing I think you're like
just talking to you I think you're
probably a great guy are you good dad
yeah I try to be when I can when I'm
around him yeah
but you know your wife's doing what's
best for him she took she got her away
from somebody who's not got him away
from somebody's not safe right
right I understand all that it's just
hard on me oh dude I can't I can't my
son's at Camp right now I can't even
breathe our whole house is a little bit
low because because one of us one of the
gangs gone right I get that yeah
but listen you can't get sober for him
I know for myself
why don't you believe that dude
I don't know I feel like
like it's hard not to like defend my
family
I know but the best way to defend your
family is you being able to defend your
family
yeah I know
who told you Sean sucks
uh
I thank him
your son
no me oh yeah but somebody
let's start those those kind of
conversations start at somebody else's
words
um
I mean I couldn't tell you that off the
top of my head when I would have ever
noticed that
okay
the way it usually works is we're born
into a family of some sort we're born
into some sort of
it's just the air we breathe when you
would know it and that's that's that's
that could be another topic here is I
I mean I have one brother no divorces my
parents been more married for four years
never moved same Elementary School all
that Sports football basketball baseball
I didn't drink till freshman year at
college and that was just barely on and
off
so what is it you thought life would
look like now
and what's different about this reality
no no but let's take drinking off the
table you thought your life would look
like something
did it include driving a tractor on your
own little place
yep so what's so Hollow about this world
right now
um not having my family home
I know dude but there's a hollowness
there that you wallpaper over with
alcohol
even if your family's sitting right
inside
that's what I haven't been able to
figure out
because you're really really focused on
external metrics haven't been to jail
they're still married for 40 years I
know a lot of silently abusive families
where everything looks great on the
outside
or really really great moms and dads who
did the best they could
but they also let one kid know that they
like the other kid better I don't know
what your story is man yeah so that that
is one thing that I've I've I I kind of
noticed that my punishments were harsher
than my brothers okay but
where is that buried and why did it come
out when it did if that is what I think
that's a problem if I were you I'd want
to know the answer to that but you can't
know that answer until you get sober
right and so going spelunking into your
past trying to fix all things mayor dude
you're doing so much all at the same
time
I want to see you make a full commitment
a full run
at going to meetings
for 60 let's do 90 days three months man
give you oh I love showing enough for
three months
and I'm gonna get a sponsor on the first
day and tell them I've been before I
didn't do it all the way I didn't go all
in I need someone I can call
and what we're going to do is we're
going to practice we are going to make a
commitment to sobriety and it will be on
that Foundation that we can start
becoming working on and practicing
becoming a better husband and Dad
all right but you got to get clean
do you trust me when I tell you you're
worth you're worth more than this
oh yeah I mean I've heard it a bunch of
times it's just and
felt like reaching out to you guys this
something different for me to think
about I'm grateful for you man how can I
help you
is there something you need uh-huh
I don't think so not right I mean I'd
like to like
talk to you again okay
I would it would make my heart full if
after 60 days you would call me back and
let me know you've been going for 60
days and I'll have you back on the show
we'll do a whole segment is that cool
that's awesome okay that's that's uh
that's our that's our deal brother you
uh you go make it happen and we'll have
you back and by the way
if you have two or three relapses over
that 60 days I still want you back man
you're in the gang now
you're in the gang I'll walk with you
for the Long Haul but you gotta have
people that you trust right next to you
that will call you out your buddies
aren't cutting your buddies aren't
cutting them
thank you for loving yourself and your
wife and your son
let's go get sober first and we'll work
on the other stuff next we'll be right
back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling hallow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right let's go to my home state of
Texas in Dallas and talk to the great
Kate what's up Kate
hey there how we doing
uh good for the most part oh no what
happened what's up
um I'm just gonna read you the email I
sent in that way I can like articulate
correctly okay
um my question so it's not very long but
it says I'm a Christian I've been a
Christian my whole life and there are
other Christians saying that the eclipse
that's happening next year has potential
to bring Doom and Gloom some articles
have said that it will be earthquakes
famine War they also say we should be
preparing for the worst we should be
storing up food and water and supplies
and I have been in just a constant state
of fear since reading it I'm stuck with
some feeling like I need to start
growing my own food which is an
incredibly overwhelming thought or that
this is just silly and I just need to
trust that God will take care of me and
my family
and it has gotten to the point that I
don't even think I want to have kids
anymore
and we've been trying to conceive for 18
months and I've been praying and reading
and I just feel really scared and really
unsure
of what to do
so when you were reading this thing
about the eclipse happening next year
and the potential to bring Doom and
Gloom to the world
I want you to know I raised my arms and
smiled really big
and then as I heard you keep talking I
feel bad so you're gonna watch this and
I'm kind of was kind of a jerk I was
kind of making fun like anybody who's
telling you that is full of more
nonsense than
I can muster on on this day today
um I don't believe that there is any
possible
thing anybody could point to in the
present in scripture in the past
whatever
that an eclipse is going to bring Doom
and Gloom okay
so I want you to hear that
or here's a better way I can say it me
and my family and I'm kind of a prepper
me and my family will not be preparing
anything special for the eclipse okay
okay that's my promise number two
my wife and I waited a long long time we
waited till we got through grad school
we waited for a long time to have kids
and we have two beautiful kids
and if I could take my head right now
and stick it in my 25 year old body
I probably would have four or five
knowing what I know right now and I've
spent my career seeing the worst of the
worst and the grossest of the gross okay
my question for you is
often when we get stuck in something
like this
it just runs on a loop in a loop and a
loop and a loop like a roller coaster
that never ends
often when I've been working with people
over the years what I found is there's
other things in their life that are out
of whack
it could be how much money you owe and
your body knows you're not safe
it could be you have an unsafe
husband
that you know you're supposed to be
married to because you have your
religious beliefs and all that but man
it's not a very good person it could be
boundary issues with your family or your
boss it could be
you have a calendar that's so bad it
could be any number of things
but if you step back away from this
one thing
what else is going on in your life
that is chaotic and anxious
that's stressed
well
um I just got
Jessica well geez Kate lead with that
oh my gosh I'm so sorry
and it was completely out of the blue
yeah um are you in pain or is it just
they no okay it's silent yeah and the
doctor she even told me she said I'm
absolutely floored
said this is one of the worst cases
she's ever seen good gracious
and I will probably have to have a full
hysterectomy by the time I'm 40. and I'm
I'm 30 now
come on hold on don't heartbreaking yeah
there's no so yeah you just gotta sit in
that
you've wanted to be a mom for a long
time haven't you
I've been scared to be a mother and then
I finally make up my mind and it's like
oh nope you gotta go through all this
why are you scared to be a mother
um I've had a very traumatic childhood
and so
I've just been scared that I won't be a
good mom
then I'll be like my mom
I think you're going to be awesome mom
because I think that crap that happened
with you as a kid
one of your life missions is that along
the the family tree that is Kate and her
family
that stops with you
Fair
completely yeah I'm proud of you
so do you see if you back out so one of
the things we do with looping Thoughts
with we really try to solve
for the eclipse
right
one of the things we do with looping
thoughts is it's the way we try to
address them and that's whether it's OCD
or whether it's anxiety or whether it's
clinical or not right these are some of
these behavioral patterns
is
we have like a house and there's a hose
in one of the windows and it's just
pumping in
poisonous gas
and as a culture we've been pumping
poisonous gas into our house for about
200 years now
and
we have spent bajillions of dollars
trying to help the people inside that
house
with breathing treatments with ways to
clean their furniture with ways to deal
with the tumors that grow inside their
bodies because they've been breathing
this air
and nobody's just backed out of the
house and looked around the street or
the neighborhood and turned off the
poisonous gas
that's a long-winded analogy to say this
your body remembers
the pain a mom can inflict
and then you married a guy he's pretty
good
he's the most amazing man in the entire
world so you won the lottery
that's not true you earned the lottery
you worked hard for this guy
and then y'all started talking about
families and kids and your body sounded
the alarms because your body knows that
story
and it's just trying to protect you
good on it it's just doing his job
you're not crazy
and then finally you do the work that it
takes to wrap your head around I'm going
to be a mom I'm gonna do this sucker
differently and I know it's going to be
hard and I know it's going to be painful
I don't have to deal with crap from my
past I'm gonna have to deal with stuff
that comes up in the future but I'm all
in
and then you get this kind of
Health news
so what I'm trying to tell you is I want
you to see your house is full of
poisonous gas I want you to see you're
not screwed up and you're not broken
okay
here's a I'm gonna give you a couple of
things that I did mine was the stock
market and housing in particular
after the housing collapse in 2008 2009
I
I went bananas
and I followed every Financial uh
conspiracy theory housing conspiracy
theory and I really I created this weird
map and all these Excel spreadsheets on
how housing was going to collapse
they're gonna have to nationalize
housing and the government was going to
own my mortgage it was a whole big mess
and Kate none of it was real
wasn't true
and at the time we owed a ton of money I
bought a house I couldn't afford I was
not in a safe job
my wife and I's marriage were falling
apart we had experienced infidelity I
mean not infidelity in uh an inability
to have kids for a long long time
and
um
my body was rattling and then I was
blaming the housing thing see what I'm
saying
do you believe me when I tell you that
me and my family are not going to be
prepping for
the eclipse
I do from what I've heard you talk about
before for sure I believe you and make
no mistake I've got a prep plan for just
about everything but I don't have one
for the eclipse okay I will probably be
out on my front yard and here's the
beautiful thing
if I'm wrong I'll be dead
I'll be dead all right what am I gonna
what am I gonna do about it if Doom and
Gloom comes after it listen if there's a
cosmic event after an eclipse
there's not a lot John delone is going
to be able to do in a backyard garden
right
yeah and I have two massive Gardens in
my house it's just not about this one
okay so here's something that I did and
became almost a sacred thing for me
you can do it however you want this is
just how I did it I'm pretty Lo-Fi
I carried a note card with me at all
times and on the front of that note card
I would I I was it's really struggling
with ADHD and a bunch of stuff I would
write down my plan for the day and I
would check it off
but I also kept on that no card when I
heard something
I have a real bad have I can walk
through a room I get a restaurant and
I'll hear one guy be like well yeah I
hear that if something's about to
collapse and my body responds as though
that is fact and it's happening in real
time
right that's what you experience too
right and now anytime you think about it
even your stomach starts to drop right
yeah yeah
I carried a note card with me and I
wrote down on that note card what was
just said
the US dollar is gonna go away
and I would look at that and say is this
true
probably not
maybe maybe but probably not
number two can I control anything about
this
yes or no
almost every time
the answer was no
and what it gave my body the ability to
do was to a acknowledge this outside of
me write it down
B go through the mental exercise what
can I actually do here
is a small suburban Garden going to
protect us if there's a cosmic event
after a eclipse no
no no
just not
a bunch of coffee and cigarettes and
bullets aren't either
those are people that watch way way too
much TV and don't live in reality
okay over time after practicing this
my body stopped being so reactive to
things I couldn't control
it was just something I had to practice
but right now it feels good doesn't it
it feels like you're doing it feels like
you're practicing the future brene Brown
says it's like dress rehearsing tragedy
as though you're gonna think it through
and think it through and think it
through so when this thing hits you'll
be ready
can I promise you something
you will not be ready for whatever thing
may happen
in the future
it's not going to be
so we're going to take it as it comes
all right what's the prognosis on your
endometriosis are they going to do
surgery
um they can't do surgery it's too far
Advanced so they have put me into
medically induced menopause okay to try
and starve it out
for six months and after six months we
will try again naturally good Wild
jersey if that works
that's a fun way to spend your 30th your
30s
yeah
how is your outlook on life as they
already started the hormone treatments
yes um
started I did start going to counseling
just to help me monitor all that because
they did say suicidal ideation was like
a common
side effects so
I'm going every other week talking to a
counselor just to make sure that I'm not
spinning out of control when did your
workout when did you start getting
worked up over the eclipse
um a couple weeks ago okay
so I've seen a counselor since then and
we briefly talked about it but
um like this morning I woke up and I was
like well we're one day closer
and I like feel like I'm just
trying to con like you said is the
control thing I think
I spent so much time being the person
that was in trouble control not actual
control but in control of how my parents
reacted to things you had to be that's
what I think I'm just responding
how I've grown up responding to things
yeah and you can't control this one you
can't control the endometriosis and you
can't control
your husband's deep deep love for you
and his he's he's gonna be sad and you
are too
yeah part of grief
and
there's gonna be heartbreak and there's
gonna be frustration and
give me all that stuff
you can't control it it's like being on
the ocean man you can't control those
waves
the path through the eclipse as it is
I want you to use this word with your
counselor say I would like to enter into
some exposure therapy
okay and that is just no that's
terrifying of course it is yeah of
course it is but it's the only path your
brain has pegged the eclipse
and anything about Eclipse anything
about starvation anything about Calamity
anything about
uh uh hurricane that happens this summer
or anything about anything about that is
gonna set that off
the only way you heal your body from
getting set off from trying to protect
you it's just doing what it was designed
to do is to head directly through the
middle of that storm
that's it
and so if you get a phobia of snakes
what they would do is they would talk
about a snake for a meeting or two yo
talk about snakes which you hated about
them what they looked like what you
thought they might feel like then the
next meeting
they would have you you draw a picture
of a snake
in the next meeting they may have you uh
with a photograph of a snake
and you're talking about it what would
it feel like and by the time you get
done you're holding a snake and you're
laughing and smiling you can't believe
your body ever reacted like this that's
that's exposure therapy it's just
walking you through it
so they're probably going to have you do
some things like
um Google the number of apocalyptic
predictions
throughout time there's a lot it's a fun
Rabbit Hole to go down if you ever don't
have anything productive to do with your
life but you can go down that rabbit
hole and uh they've all been wrong
because we're all still here
and one day there will be one there will
I'm confident
I'm also confident
at least the best I can
it's not gonna come on the back of an
eclipse
hang on the line here I'm going to send
you two things I'm going to send you my
book redefining anxiety I'm also going
to send you own your past change your
future for you and your husband okay I
want y'all both to read that book
um and you want you to read the anxiety
books it'll give you some short term and
long-term things it may be over time
after you get your hormones regulated
you're just I mean you're gonna it's
gonna be a while it's gonna be a messy
messy ride that's a tough tough road to
hoe
um
but it may be that I need some anxiety
meds for a short short season it may be
that I need to get another job start a
new exercise whatever that happens to be
[Music]
but you're on a path
I'm really proud of you for calling
I'm really proud of you for
considering going to your counselor and
say let's let's Stare this sucker down
let's tear this monster right in the
face and walk right up to it you're
gonna find out
that monster was just smoke all of them
we'll be right back
all right we are back let's go out to
Doug in Winston-Salem North Carolina
what's up D
hey how you doing buddy we're getting it
man how about you
oh same same awesome what's up my man
how can I help
uh well
I'm having some issues uh
I I I could use some advice on having
how to navigate things
um
[Music]
over 600 pounds uh I was almost 700
um
I lost 300 pounds probably almost 10
years ago and uh wow I ended up putting
it back on
and uh
it got and I was working at a factory
I started getting a really bad plantars
fasciitis you know
and it kind of It kind of led me to have
to leave that job
and uh ended up putting on like 50 more
pounds and I originally had and uh
everything is just a mess right now
um
like I still live at home with my mom
um I'm 42 years old
uh
um I
work uh
let's see
24 hours a month at a part-time job
and even there I have to have
I have to have assistance doing things
and um I'm just at a at a low point to
where there's so much going on
that needs fixing
that I don't even know where to start
yeah I mean
yeah man uh yeah
sorry no don't be sorry brother
yeah I just I don't know where that I
don't know where I would uh
I don't know I I would I know that I
would probably be homeless within a few
weeks
but
I don't know I'm just
just kind of lost
um
I've had you know people
you know try to help me and everything
and uh I feel like I'm just
I'll let everybody down
and um
I don't know I'm just I
I'm kind of bitter about my old self
whenever I was whenever I lost all of my
weight and everything
um
life was just really starting to get
good
and uh
I don't know
and uh so let me ask you this my brother
what do you want to be different
wrap your fingers for me you snap your
fingers for me right now
what would be different
I wouldn't be independent
what does that mean
that's a that's a that's a fantasy
that's like unicorns what tell me
exactly what that looks like
okay
September okay
you get repoed or do you wreck it yeah
it got repoed okay
no
I would I would
I would have worked to uh
support myself okay
um and be able to help my friends out
when they needed it
uh
I'll be able to love people better
um
I'll be able to be the friend that
people need
uh you know you know who
man
they don't make hearts like here any
yours anymore Doug
nah man I'm being serious that's my
promise on this show I promise I'm gonna
tell you the truth and I'll be I'll be
I'll be hard on you in a minute but
I need you to hear me say it man
like
that is not the answer I was expecting
you got a heart you're
gold pulses through your veins my
brother
it's not normal
and let me tell you this
the person that you have to make friends
with first
is who
myself and I I can't even understand to
look at myself I know you can I know you
can't I know you can't
when's the last time you had human touch
in your life somebody other than your
mom how's your hand
uh
like um
like a hug or something yeah
um
oh gosh from somebody else
I can count on one hand all right
since 2020 I can count on one hand and
probably still have plenty of fingers
left up yeah
so I'm gonna ask you a hard question
okay
yeah are you done
what do you mean
well it sounds like you've reached
a decision making point
and either way you're going to be done
are you done with
the first 42
it's half time
you just got your butt kicked in the
first half but y'all gonna regroup
in the locker room you're gonna come out
for the second half firing on all
cylinders
so are you done living this life that
you got
yeah or are you done like I'm cashing
out man
I'm just cashing out
[Applause]
I want to be the first one
but sometimes
just cashing out things
you know
it's it's certainly the easiest thing
it is because I know I know there is
this is going to be
like a big
gosh I can't keep myself together
I know it was going to be a big fight
um
but uh but the war is with one person
yeah the war's with Doug
yeah
and the beauty of going to war with
yourself is you don't have to fight
yeah right
yeah
here's here's what I want you to say I
heard you rattle off weight autonomy I
want my own place I want to be able to
serve my buddies again I can't work very
much and even when I do I'm embarrassed
and I feel ashamed that I get help doing
this stuff
um haven't haven't been hugged or
haven't held someone's hand in years
right
depressed low all that stuff
your job isn't to try to fix all these
things at the same time
okay
your job is to slowly inch by inch be
calm somebody that Doug is proud of
here's the cool thing
you have lived a life the last decade
that I am not strong enough to have
lived
yes you have done immeasurably hard
things
simply moving through the world
navigating the world things that I do on
a daily basis that I don't even give one
second of thought to
is a Monumental task it's something that
takes High coordination and high
intentionality just to do it
yeah like moving 30 feet even that's
what I'm talking about it tastes like a
nuclear reactor to get my legs to move
that's that's what I'm saying
so listen to me
you are infinitely
stronger than I am
the question I have for you and it's an
old dumb internet question you probably
heard a thousand times
which hard are you gonna choose man
because the life you live right now is
really really hard
and losing 400 pounds will be really
hard
yeah right it's both and
so it's not a matter of one being easy
it's not a matter of one being simple
simpler than the other it's a matter of
which harder you're going to choose
because you got heart in front of you
right
unless you just quit and I'm gonna tell
you right now
you're not gonna quit
no because they don't make hearts like
yours and I need you in this crazy
screwed up world we live in because I
got two little kids that are counting on
people like you to make a difference so
you don't get to quit Fair
yeah definitely you believe me when I
tell you that
yeah yeah
okay
Doug doesn't get to quit Doug just has
to choose his heart man
yeah and like sometimes
like
I think uh
I don't know like whenever I lost all
that weight you know
sometimes
that is the only thing that gives me
hope is because I know I can do it of
course you can
it's uh there's not a doubt in my mind
now can I be hard on you for a second
yeah
what kind of role does your mom play
uh someone's got to be getting you all
the food someone's got to be bringing
all the stuff to you somebody has a
vested interest in you staying down is
that your mom
yeah
I'm living off of like 400 not even four
hundred dollars
so and the person who is taking care of
you
is also using you to make herself feel
better is that right
yeah I'm yeah I mean she she's the
shoulder-ish I mean she can't do a lot
so no no I'm talking about who's
bringing you all this food dog
it's
I guess it's just a combined effort uh
I mean we go to the food pantry when uh
they load us up
they give us uh whatever we can get you
know okay
um
but uh do you have the internet at home
oh yeah do you have Instagram
yeah all right you have a pen in front
of you
um
or you can type it into your phone okay
I want you to write down the name Ethan
souply
e-t-h-a-n-s-u-p-l-e-e
okay all right
when we get off this call I want you to
subscribe to his Instagram page
and I want you to go down a rabbit hole
reading every post that he writes
reading all of the captions that he
writes okay
um he's in one of my favorite actors
who's ever lived and I've never met the
guy
but I've been so moved by his
transformation
from who he was to who he is now
and I think you all have
he'll be able to speak authentically
into you okay
before we get off the phone
we're gonna do a couple of things all
right
okay thing number one
do you read will you read a book if I
send it to you for free
oh yeah all right I'm gonna send you my
book for free
I'm also going to send you my buddy Dave
Ramsey's book Total Money Makeover for
free
I'm also I'm gonna send you
my company's Flagship product Financial
Peace University that teaches you how to
deal with money I'm gonna send that to
you for free too all the videos and
everything okay oh wow but listen I know
that you're going well got any money to
even know how to manage you will you
will
okay
yeah
but here's what I want you to start
experiencing is microscopic little wins
teeny tiny little winds
now yeah if I'm you I would go hire a
coach I would hire a therapist I would
do all you don't have that access right
now because of for financial constraints
correct exactly okay you live in a
snapshot of History
where the greatest Minds on the planet
are putting things up for free workout
plans nutrition plans ideas ways to
communicate with themselves or just
putting it up for free
okay
I want you
to begin to be your own best Advocate
and you never have been Doug and it's
got to start today
oh okay so yeah
I'm not in a nutrition expert I'm not
someone who can walk you through how do
you where do you even start if you weigh
620 pounds that information exists on
online okay yeah but you have to be
determined to go get it
yeah
and that starts with doing something
really important okay yeah you have to
change the identity man
from an overweight obese loser who still
lives with his mom who can't even work
and so people have to help him
you got to change your identity too I'm
a guy who loves Doug
yeah
and I'm a guy who treats Doug with
respect and dignity
and respect and dignity means I don't
poison myself anymore both psychologic
mentally and physically with food
I'm Doug and I believe in something
bigger than myself
I've lived for decades as an obese man
and I can do hard things I'm just gonna
have to do different hard things
yeah
do you believe me
oh man
I just threw a bunch at you what do you
think
am I full of crap are you are you in no
I'm in I'm
I'm definitely yeah what's your weight
number today
uh last last
okay
once you get on a plan
an actual plan
when that number Hits gets a four in
front
I want you to take a picture of that
scale and email it into the show and I'm
going to send you a check for a thousand
dollars how about that
okay
Fair
yeah that sounds Beyond Fair all right
also I'm Gonna Get You six months of
free counseling with my friends at
betterhelp
okay and you're gonna have to talk to
somebody but dude you gotta do it
yeah
okay right um yeah like uh
I've tried to get like Medicaid and
stuff like that I know I got you well I
don't I don't have I don't have you on
the physical stuff
but I can take care of the other stuff
for a season okay so I want you to talk
to a counselor it's digital so you can
do it from your phone you can do it from
your laptop sitting in your house you
don't have to go anywhere
these are real licensed therapist and I
got you for six months cool wow yeah
definitely
and when you're when your number on your
scale has a three in front of it it can
be 399.9
I'm gonna send you a free dream Cloud
king size mattress change your life
oh wow cool wow yeah so this is what
deloni I'm calling your bluff brother
all right if you're in we'll walk with
you
yeah let's do it okay
yeah yeah you promise
I do
all right
I love you Doug
thank you buddy I love y'all I
appreciate y'all
no you didn't hear me you rolled it off
because you don't you you you are so
grossed out by Doug you can't even hear
it
Doug I love you and I'm grateful for you
and I'm glad you're here
thank you okay
this does not start tomorrow this starts
today
yeah
it starts right now
yeah you head down the rabbit hole I
want you to have a pen and a little
notebook with you next to you and I want
you to write down the things from
Ethan's Instagram page that that means
something to you
May reach out to him he may not respond
because he's he's kind of a big deal but
he's just got so many people following
him but listen
the journey starts Ted day not tomorrow
yeah and that might be five tiny little
exercises
that's day one that might be five tiny
little here's five things I like about
Doug even you it might take you a while
but you're gonna get there
yeah
here are five changes I'm gonna make
with the food I put in my body and not
something stupid like I'm only eating
one meal that's not sustainable we're
changing our life now
okay yeah
cool
yeah
all right
we'll walk alongside you man but you
gotta lead the way you in uh
yeah are you giving up on me
I'll give you a hell no on this one Doug
I'll give it to you all right okay yeah
yeah all right hang on the line and
we'll get you hooked up my brother I'm
proud of you think ah thank you thank
you thank you for calling proud of you
and uh and I can't wait to see that
would be the happiest thousand dollar
check I ever write in my life
can't wait you in yeah yeah I'm in
excellent excellent excellent excellent
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well-life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's man today's
a special show it was good it was good
man we got three people that I think are
ready to change their life it's awesome
awesome awesome such an honor to be able
to
be one tiny little brick on the
paved Road of their Adventure that's
coming up man so awesome to walk
alongside folks
song of the day as far as second caller
near and dear to my heart man
it's from the great REM and the song is
it's the end of the world as we know it
except not from an eclipse
song goes like this that's great
starts with an earthquake birds and
snakes and airplanes and Lenny Bruce is
not afraid
I have a hurricane
it's the end of the world as we know it
hey I feel fine I love you guys bye